hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
coca-cola is the world's most valuable
non technology brand they make anything
from soft drinks to bottled water milk
juices iced tea and coffee
they own a 21 different billion dollar
brand every single day two billion
servings of a coke brand are served
worldwide but how do they start and how
did they grow to the massive size they
are today today we're going to look at
how they made arguably the most popular
product on the planet and diversified
across the beverage market to create
over 500 brands and over 3500 beverages
but before we get to that a quick word
from today's sponsor I just want to give
a shout out to Squarespace for helping
make this video possible Squarespace is
one of the easiest ways to build a
website there's nothing to patch or
upgrade ever and it's flexible the end
result looks professional and the whole
process makes building website easy if
you're looking to build your own website
start your free trial today visit
[Music]
coca-cola was created by dr. John
Pemberton and Atlanta pharmacist in 1995
he set up his own laboratory and started
to patent and produces eye medicines
such as head eyes and liver pills
he wasn't very successful though then
one day while trying to create a new
tonic he combined the extracts of the
coca leaf the main ingredient for
cocaine the African Kola nut along with
some sugar and some water
although the Kola nut already contains
caffeine he boosted the caffeine content
even more his main idea was that he
could sell this as a headache remedy
after some testing however he saw that
it helped with indigestion and relieved
exhaustion Pemberton and his partners
were unsure what to do with this new
drink now called coca-cola on the one
hand it seemed to have some medicinal
qualities but on the other hand the
flavor was delicious and that alone
should make it popular in the end they
went for both an early advertisement
stated makes not only a delicious and
invigorating beverage
I wonder why but a valuable brain tonic
and a cure for all nervous affections so
in 1887 coke went on sale from the
get-go it had that famous curly script
logo that was actually designed by
Pemberton's bookkeeper
coke was first sold as a syrup to
pharmacies and other dispensaries where
they had soda fountains soda fountains
with a big thing it was like a gathering
place for people to discuss the topics
of the day the new gathering place of a
new age the soda fountain helping to
make the 90's game this coke syrup was
the very first coca-cola product
Pemberton and his partners spent 74
dollars in advertising their new syrup
but the response was slow they only made
fifty dollars in sales in the first year
so Pemberton sold most of his company to
another drug manufacturer another name
of ASA Candler
three years later Pemberton was dead and
mr. canler own coca-cola for just $2,300
our rate which is about $60,000 in
today's money and rightly so at the time
it seemed like a useless company but
over the next 26 years
canler oversaw the company's rapid early
growth in 1892 the company started a
promotional campaign that included
giving our coupons of coke for a free
sample once people tried the free
samples they came back for more forking
out five cents a glass thereafter the
campaign was hugely successful
it took Coke just three years to enter
every state of the United States and
soon they crossed over the border north
to Canada this masked coupon initiative
was extremely forward-thinking for the
time back then giving a product away
sounded foolish but can larger
confidence in the coke product by
knowing that people would come back for
more but there was a problem and it was
in the name at the start of the 20th
century
canler was worried about the public's
perception towards cocaine this was
going to harm sales however he felt that
he couldn't remove the coke or plant
entirely as he may risk losing the
coca-cola name so they fixed the recipe
so it was just the smallest trace of
cocaine remained it wasn't until 1929
that it was removed entirely around this
time kendall also moved the drink away
from its original branding as a health
tonic all they can louis doing a good
job he did make one major miscalculation
though he thought the company's future
as being heavily based on the soda
fountain scene
other companies have been buying the
syrup and selling them in mixed soda
bottles but candle it didn't really see
much value on this and I love these
other companies to bottle the product
just for one dollar this was a huge
mistake and soon there were knockoff
brands of coke everywhere the names are
pretty funny and some included cockin
Ola
macoco a CO and toca Cola Pepsi Cola was
another such knockoff but it wouldn't be
noticed till the 1970s more on this
later the solution came in the form of
trading a bottle shape and design so
unique the customers could tell it apart
just by feeling it when they stuck their
hand in a cooler the result was the
famous curvy glass bottle that became so
iconic in popular culture Kandla would
soon retire and passed the reigns down
to Robert Woodruff Roberts streamlined
the production process and managed to
create a product that tasted the same
everywhere so all consumers could get
the same experience World War two would
erupt in 1939 but would actually prove
to be hugely beneficial to the company
as the US troops entered fighting
Woodruff announced that every US soldier
will be able to buy a coke for five
cents no matter how much it cost the
company the move would see cokes at our
bottling plants around the world from
Germany to North Africa in order to
still make reasonable revenue and handle
the demand of the US soldiers around the
world the German coca-cola plants had
been set up before the war started but
once fighting began and trade embargoes
were set in place it became impossible
to keep trading Coca Cola syrup so the
plant was forced to make a new drink out
of what they could buy mainly apple
leftovers from juicing and leftover
liquid from milk production they called
this concoction Fanta by the end of the
war coke had become a part of America's
national identity and the rest of the
world would be next throughout the 50s
they opened 15 to 20 plants a year
dotted all over the planet then in the
1960s they began to diversify and
started acquiring other successful
beverage companies such as Minute Maid
and hi-c fruit drinks they would also
launch sprite tab as well as Diet
versions of the drink this was in part
to tackle the growing competition from
Pepsi the company struggled through the
late 1960s and 70s especially in Europe
where the beverage industry threatened
to have the
and blind tests in the early 1970s was
showing that people like the taste of
Pepsi better can you tell me which one
you prefer
you're both sure you like L better right
what was your choice fact is a test like
these nationwide more people prefer the
taste of Pepsi over coca-cola the sales
of Pepsi began to climb and the Pepsi
challenge was kicked off across America
all across America people are taking the
Pepsi challenge this scenario became
known as the cola wars by 1975 Pepsi was
number one at the start of the 1980s
Roberto Kazuto became chairman and
decided that changes needed to be made
in 100 years the company had grown
hugely but had largely stuck to
tradition soon after he joined he heard
the celebration that coca-cola had
gained 45 percent of the soft drink
market so he went in crunched the
numbers and came back to tell everyone
that sure they were succeeding of soft
drinks but they had less than 2% of the
entire liquid beverage market share that
became the new target
Roberto injected some much-needed
ambition into the company he also
launched Diet Coke when no other head of
the company was brave enough to risk the
classic coca-cola brand
it was soon established as the world's
number three soft drink diet coke helped
change the tide but more needed to be
done
secret labs were set up for Coke
chemists to find the perfect formula to
beat Pepsi it was finally found in 1985
and put up against Pepsi and the
original version of Coke in 200,000
taste tests across the country it beat
both of the other products and seemed to
be a winner
my answer to you is of course the best
always do simply stated my friends we
have a new formula for Coke consumers
preferred the new taste over the
original by a margin of 61 to 39 the
company was so confident that they would
scrap the original formula of Coke after
100 years of success this new drink was
called new coke and the company got none
other than Bill Cosby to promote it even
though the test proved that the new Coke
was superior human psychology meant that
the public just didn't like change
[Music]
at one point complaints reached over
8,000 per day the new code became one of
the worst blunders in marketing history
and Bill Cosby would later be the same
at one point communist dictator Fidel
Castro stated that the end of the
original Koch formula was a sign of
American decay Koch was more than just a
sugary drink coca-cola stood for the
American Way of life in the end that the
public had spoken the feeling of loyalty
for Koch was so strong that when Koch
reverted back to the original formula
people longed for what was about to be
taken away from them soon Koch became
number one again and has stayed in that
position ever since but what many people
may not know is that the new Koch was
still offered to put all distributors up
until 2002 by the time Robert died in
1997 he had taken Coca Cola's market
share from 4.3 billion to 147 billion
his drive to do better paid off
[Music]
so what does the coca-cola company look
like today they have a huge roster of
brands now over 500 and have a huge
amount of diversity in the beverage
industry with everything from coke to
water two juices and dairy they also
just launched their first alcoholic
drink in Japan and it was an hour cope
up the revenues in 2017 were thirty five
billion dollars which continues to stay
decline that we've been seeing since
they peaked at 48 billion in 2012 and
this was after consumers became more
health conscious still at his current
revenue Co could be the 84th largest
economy in the world all right so let's
look at 12 interesting facts about Coke
it'll give you an idea of their size and
other interesting things about them as
well on an ask you a question if you
were to drink every single one of cokes
different beverages at a rate of one per
day how long do you think it would take
you maybe a couple of months maybe a
year well not really
it would taking over nine years to try
them all the Coca Cola brand itself is
estimated to be worth 74 billion dollars
that's more than Budweiser
Pepsi is Starbucks and redbull combined
if every drop of coke ever produced will
put an 8 ounce bottles laid end to end
they would reach to the moon and back
over 2,000 times the red and white Coca
Cola logo is recognized by 94 percent of
the world's population is the second
most recognized brand on earth behind
Nike there are 33 non-alcoholic brands
that generate over 1 billion dollars in
revenue and coca-cola owns 15 of them
Coke also sells more than a thousand
kinds of juice drinks coca-cola spends
more money on advertising than Microsoft
and Apple combined and their secret to
long term advertising success always
associating their product with a good
feeling
[Music]
this establishes a positive emotional
connection whenever a consumer sees the
product they were one of the first
companies to do this
[Music]
Americans ingest 1.7 million tons of
coke or about 11 pounds 5 kilos per
person each year from coca-cola alone
and on that note coke is actually pretty
terrible for you
it can cause obesity and metabolic
disease the company has been caught
paying millions of dollars to fund
research papers playing down these facts
in the mid-2000s it was revealed that
some of the water being sold under the
coke brand was simply purified tap water
the average Mexican drinks more coke
products than the average American
British Indian and Chinese combined coke
uses 300,000 tons of aluminium for its
cans every year just for its US
operations that's equal to about 17
point four percent of what the entire US
aluminium industry produces there are
only two countries in the world where
coca-cola isn't sold Cuba and North
Korea Coke is the reason why Santa is
fat and wears a red suit prior to 1931
Santa was depicted as everything from a
tall gaunt man to a spooky-looking elf
he was often adorned in the bishops robe
and wore an animal skin a popular coke
advert in 1931 made Santa look more
wholesome realistic and jolly and this
was the origin of the Santa we imagine
today so there you go and that just
about rounds at the end of the video the
story of Coca Cola is a pretty
interesting one from a chemist mistake
all the way to one of the most
recognized brands on the planet and a
cultural icon so thanks for watching
this has been - go go you've been
watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe and I'll see you again soon
for the next video
Jia's guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]